the biggest area that needed the most
help was female hormone health so that's
the area that the Delta value between
here's how bad it is and how good it
could be huge gap and every woman was
kind of told well you're a woman you're
supposed to have these problems it's
hormones right that you're supposed to
have a crazy menopause and infertility
and PCOS and all these problems which no
you don't have to have if you understood
the genetics of the hormone Cascade and
what's that thing that makes it more
difficult for women is there something
called estrogen toxicity so
when you make your hormones on a monthly
basis progesterone becomes testosterone
becomes estrogen and in that Cascade you
can do those at different rates and
speeds so fill different buckets at
different levels and once you finally
fill the estrogen bucket you then have
three options two four or 16
hydroxyestrogen two is the good clean
stuff you want 4 and 16 are toxic 16
being more toxic than four and a lot of
the women we're seeing that are coming
to us saying I have fibromyalgia I have
infertility issues endometriosis crazy
migraines mood issues they're making
these two metabolites now why is this a
problem of today's generation because
the genome alone is not enough the
genome is here's how your body works
here's the red flag let's prioritize
this now we need to understand your
epigenetic habits what is your
environment what is your nutrition what
is your lifestyle and the pairing of
those two is your net result
and the reality is that today the
hormone disrupting threats are so
prolific
that there's so many more problems so
the women that were estrogen toxic in
Grandma's generation didn't get sick
they were truck they were toxic it
caused some inflammation but the body
can handle some inflammation now the
total load is so much that it's causing
all these issues including breast cancer
and this was a big thing we learned and
we can now deal with that root cause and
make sure that women don't get sick
got it so there are so many things in
our environment like Plastics and food
and
um the air that we breathe from all of
the chemicals being sprayed in the air
to EMF disrupting frequency
all of those things they but especially
the consumables like drinking out of
plastic and the stuff in our food that
is estrogen that creates more estrogen
yeah it's your body treats it as if it's
additional estrogen right so it did
that's why it's called estrogen mimic so
it mimics us so it's not actually
estrogen when it enters your body your
body gets infused thinks it's estrogen
so genes turn on to convert it into that
estrogen byproduct which is toxic and
inflammatory because estrogen is such a
female hormone does it is it kind of
amping that up like making more female
like I think about female like having
curvier bodies or like just like does it
continue to does it make you more woman
too so that's what's happening to men so
that's kind of what I was gonna ask next
is this something that's happening to
men and is this why perhaps we're seeing
um more shifting with men to women
whether it's through transitioning same
Cascade that I said progesterone become
testosterone comes men do the exact same
thing we just do it daily men have men
have a daily cycle women have a monthly
cycle same exact cycle and men are more
likely to be more androgenized more
testosterone women are more likely to be
more exercise so now the answer to that
question isn't a blanket answer it
depends on what your hormones look like
so someone like you who's more
androgenized more chiseled features
petite frame right that's more
testosterone so that's going to drive
you from androgenized to call it what
the typical estrogenized woman would
have been right now a woman who's
already estrogen dominant is now gonna
not maybe get more curvier figures but
she's gonna start to get some of the um
conditions like fiber fibromyalgia
endometriosis you know crazy migraines
mood issues because she's
overestrogenized and if she's also toxic
too much inflammation what we're seeing
with the men
um
the I guess the the change in culture
and the femininity amount around among
men yeah there's no surprise when you're
taking what used to be a manly man you
know and you're removing all of what
creates testosterone the fight the Vigor
the the training the exercise and your
sedentary and so there's a funny thing
with hormones
when you sort of lean forward and fight
that calls on your body to create more
testosterone
when you create some more testosterone
it calls on your body to lean forward
and fight and you get on this vicious
cycle forward
right same is true the backwards the
opposite I should say if you kind of
lean back like I'm not going to do it
you get more estrogenized the the
warrior versus The Warrior
right and so we all now have a warrior
lifestyle sit in a chair and type right
and be afraid of everything everything
is a problem and don't train don't fight
don't do anything Politically Incorrect
you know tone yourself down and so we're
all going into this Warrior mode which
is also an estrogen problem
all of us right so uh the men that are
out there saying let's do something and
rile ourselves up and become men there's
something to be said there in terms of
not losing half of our gender right
what's the solution
well the solution it depends I mean if
if it's like
is it a pill yeah there's pills or is it
a culture shift yeah that's probably
necessary also you know where there's
some things we're trying to fix right
there's some which need to be fixed
inclusion yes let's fix inclusion
because there's some people I have had
two business partners uh in the last few
years that are both gay right and they
need to be included and not be
discriminated against right right and
but the but what is also true is a
person who does isn't innately you know
uh by choice or by birth but more by
influence of chemicals and hormones and
you know confusion unnatural right that
was not their who they naturally are
right right so you're you're taking away
the identity of someone who actually is
something and then lending it to
somebody to create confusion uh and a
lot of that has to do with hormone
disruption we're seeing it over and over
and over and over and over again so the
to answer your question
the chemicals are disruptive the birth
control is disruptive the Teflon coated
frying pans are disrupted the Plastics
are disrupted so understand that
ancestral habits are the healthiest
habits that's what we are still wired
for our bodies have not caught up
genetically to cope with all of that
Plastics don't clear your body they
cause cancer and they just float around
forever right forever chemicals don't
leave it was about a month ago I read
this article about Lululemon pants being
loaded with uh fluorine which is a
forever chemical which just doesn't
leave you know and it's very
specifically in the crotch lining which
is when you're sweating with an opening
taking in the fluorine you know yeah
amazing right so um just understanding
so to answer your question understanding
how prolific hormone disruption is in
your environment in your food and
everything you do from the chemicals
you're spraying on your tabletop to the
pesticides in your lawn what is hormone
disruptive what is not understand that
second is
it's sole prolific that it may even be
hard to manage even then so you may
decide that hormone treatment is
beneficial for you right you may still
want to be the manly man or the womanly
woman and you may want to take hormones
because our reality again is not
Grandma's reality our genes are their
genes but our context is different we're
in a different bucket with different
problems that we are not designed for so
we need more intervention
we need more supplementation or whether
it's hormones or even just things like
dim that slow down the estrogen pathway
simple supplement it's a broccoli
extract right so it's a combination of
these two things understanding the
threats eliminating them understanding
what you can do to add in supplement to
turn the dial up on your capacity to be
that person you were supposed to be the
this area that scares me the most right
now which is our food and you know the
the the the scare of
mRNA being added into
animals and foods for our consumption
like what the hell's going on how's that
going to go more towards again our sort
of biological nature is this meant
affect our genetics
so let me tell you a story
right now in the state of Missouri
there's a bill that's trying to be
passed I think it's Bill 1169
that says that
foods that have mRNA technology in them
need labeling to warn people that this
may alter your genome
and the current state is there's a lot
of pushback by big food and big Pharma
why is there pushback if there's no
problem
so since 2018 so mRNA we know of it post
covet right we think it's a brand new
thing that landed in 2020
mRNA for pigs started developing in
2012.
it's been used in pork since 2018. the
pork you've been eating since 2018 has
mRNA technology in it that's not a
secret yeah it's made by moderna and
Merck and and now yeah and now here's
the really wonderful part of the story
is the way it was designed is there's a
baseline product which is called the
delivery method and because it's mRNA
and it's custom they respond to each
unique virus by creating this custom
portion that then gets injected into
that flock of pigs right that's custom
portion which is the active portion has
no requirement for safety check from FDA
because this yeah
because this thing is approved this
Baseline was approved went through all
the vigorous whatever is required the
it's a custom product so how can we
possibly approve a custom product we
have to immediately respond to whatever
the new virus is so this thing does not
require approval and this is why the
state of Missouri who's trying to
prevent which is you know such a big
part of their
um
sort of their ecosystem farming and
agriculture they're saying no we don't
understand what this does yet and you
can't prove to us that it doesn't do
what we're worried that it does
please put a label that's all we're
saying in this bill to warn people and
there's major major pushback why is
there pushback because the what is the
label claim this may alter your Human
Genome so if you have a signal an mRNA
signal that's designed to edit something
how do we know it doesn't stop at the
animal that was injected in
if you're eating it well why are they
injecting the animal in the first place
other than to give it to us is there a
reason well it's it's meant to be like
antiviral so you know protecting so
their vaccines have been used in animals
for some antibiotics right so they're
just saying here's a better way to do it
it's custom for the actual strain and
that local Farm or area uh yeah I don't
get it it doesn't add up you know
there's right now there's over 100
million wild animals that are being
injected with mRNA
Yeah so basically just infect the planet
because if they're wild they're gonna
and let me just like check and balance
this real quick because you said that we
haven't had our genes really changed
since 250 000 years ago so is this on an
epigenetic level that we're being
alter or is this a baseline genetic
thing so the scary thing is we don't
know
we don't really know what this stuff
does uh but what we do know is crispr
technology exists and what we do know at
the you know uh biotech level me being
in the Biotech Industry is it's not it's
not ready for me to develop a product
yet right I I have tried to make
products like for example I know that I
can prevent cardiovascular disease if I
can alter the 9p21 gene which gives you
a more robust endothelial lining the
arterial walls if I make your arterial
walls stainless steel you're not getting
cardiovascular disease I need that
because remember I had terrible veins
yeah so you know you get a trade-off you
got yeah you get a little bit of a good
little bit of bad so what I'm trying to
do is fix the bed which is if I can make
a crispr technology product Gene editing
gene therapy then great I can fix that
problem so I'm being told right now I
can't do that meanwhile
um we don't know who has access to what
right the theory three crispr works so
is it that it's not yet available or is
it just not yet available to me
if you like this clip and you want to
hear the whole episode click at the
bottom of your screen